Like the "Rocky" franchise before it, it's clear
that "Creed" can go the distance. With the third
installment hitting theaters soon, here's the
tale of the tape on this hard-hitting sequel.
The first two "Creed" films were both
released in November — November 25,
2015 and November 21, 2018, to be exact — but
"Creed III" is bucking the trend. Originally,
it was supposed to hit theaters in November 2022,
but now, it has moved back to March 3, 2023.
Why the change from late fall to late winter/early
spring? "Black Panther: Wakanda Forever" was
released in November 2022, so it's a good bet
that United Artists and Warner Bros. didn't
want to compete with that Marvel blockbuster.
And it's likely Ryan Coogler, the director of
"Wakanda Forever" and an executive producer on
"Creed III," didn't want to compete with himself.
So why not move it to November 2023? Most
likely because Warner Bros. is releasing
another massive film that month — "Dune:
Part Two" — and chances are good the studio
doesn't want two of its biggest films
duking it out for box office dominance.
"Now we past talkin'."
"Then maybe you just have to fight him."
In the first "Creed" film, our titular
hero entered the world of prizefighting,
with a cancer-stricken Rocky Balboa as his
mentor. With the former champ by his side,
Adonis "Donnie" Creed grappled with his father's
complicated legacy and trained for a championship
fight. The sequel saw Donnie and Rocky dealing
with the father-son pugilists Ivan and Viktor
Drago. Ivan fought Rocky in "Rocky IV" after
killing Donnie's dad, Apollo Creed, in the ring.
Despite coming to terms with his family history,
the past isn't done with Adonis Creed just yet.
In the third installment of the franchise, which
takes place seven years after the second film,
everything seems to be going right for
Donnie. He's the light heavyweight champion,
his musician wife Bianca is successful in
her own right, and everything is going great
with their daughter, Amara. But that's
when Damian "Dame" Anderson shows up.
Damian and Donnie were childhood friends,
but while the young Creed found success in the
ring, Damian wound up in prison for 18 years.
Now, he's out — and he's got some issues
with his former friend. A boxer himself,
Damian feels robbed of his career, and he's here
to take everything Adonis has. Once like brothers,
these two rivals will have to settle
their differences inside the ring.
The trailer for "Creed III" digs into
Donnie's relationship with Dame. After
Donnie thanks the people in
his life for their success…
"Bianca. Rocky. My dad. This
is built on their shoulders."
A quick flashback shows Donnie and Dame as young
boys, arms in the air, surrounded by cops. This
is likely the incident that sent Damian to prison
for 18 years. When his old friend is free, Donnie
invites Dame back to the gym, and he's an absolute
monster in the ring. Naturally, animosity builds.
"You think you mad? Try spending
half your life in a cell,
watching somebody else live your
life. I'm coming for everything."
The trailer ends with the two titans throwing down
in the ring in the match touted
as the "Battle for Los Angeles."
"Creed III" features an absolutely stacked cast
of Hollywood A-listers. Michael B. Jordan reprises
the role of Adonis "Donnie" Creed, and Tessa
Thompson also returns to play Bianca. Their
daughter, Amara, is played by Mila Davis-Kent.
Other returning familiar faces include Phylicia
Rashad as Donnie's mom, Mary Anne Creed,
and Wood Harris as Tony "Little Duke" Evers,
Creed's trainer. We'll also get to see the
return of Florian Munteanu as Viktor Drago.
A new addition to the cast is Jonathan Majors as
Damian "Dame" Anderson. Majors has made quite a
name for himself recently, starring in projects
like the horror series "Lovecraft Country" and
the Western "The Harder They Fall." Of course,
he also appeared as He Who Remains in "Loki" and
is set to be the MCU's next big bad as Kang the
Conqueror in "Ant-Man and the Wasp: Quantumania."
Boxing fans should also keep an eye out for
cameos, too. Multiple-time champion Canelo
Álvarez will be making his acting debut in the
film, and former cruiserweight champion Tony
Bellew will reprise his role as Ricky Conlan,
the antagonist of the first "Creed" film.
Unfortunately, one major player who
won't be coming back in "Creed III"
is Sylvester Stallone. In July
2022, he explained to Metro,
Saying the third film takes things in a
"different direction," Stallone
offered encouragement, saying,
But Stallone was a bit more critical in an
interview with the Hollywood Reporter, saying,
After parts on TV shows including "The Wire," and
"Friday Night Lights," Michael B. Jordan finally
found A-list stardom by teaming up with director
Ryan Coogler and playing in a trio of powerful
films — "Fruitvale Station," "Black Panther," and
"Creed." Now, after two decades in the business,
Jordan is stepping behind the camera for
the first time to direct "Creed III."
"It's something I'm eternally grateful for."
According to Variety, Jordan
said in a press conference,
Jordan has gotten wisdom from some
of the best. According to Empire,
he has learned about directing while acting from
Denzel Washington and Bradley Cooper. He also
received guidance from Ryan Coogler.
Jordan shared that Coogler told him,
As for the screenplay, Jordan will
be working off a script written by
Zach Baylin and Keenan Coogler, who also
worked with Ryan Coogler on the story.